in diesem video geht es darum welche
gemüse man im september noch säen und
pflanzen kann und das sind richtig
richtig viele nicht den fehler machen
dass ihr nur im frühling einmal gemüse
in euren garten sieht oder pflanzt man
muss wenn man das ganze jahr über aus
seinem garten ernten möchte auch das
ganze jahr über oder fast das ganze jahr
über immer wieder gemüse nach sehen und
nach pflanzen und wahrscheinlich sind in
euren beten ja jetzt schon ganz viele
lücken entstanden von denen gewesen die
aufgegessen sind und deswegen da jetzt
einfach neue gemüse nachschieben einfach
wählen und pflanzen was das zeug hält
auch damit euer boden den winter über
bewachsen ist das ist also auch für den
boden super super sinnvoll wenn man das
ganze jahr über gemüse anbaut und nicht
nur im frühling und sommer weil er dann
vor erosion geschützt wird deswegen
starten wir jetzt in die september
ausarten zusammen los geht's
graphen regnitz deswegen habe ich mein
kleines studio hier jetzt mal im
gewächshaus aufgebaut wir fangen an mit
den finanzen die man jetzt im haus
vorziehen kann also in töpfchen aus der
at das ist deswegen sinnvoll weil die
beete draußen ja vielleicht jetzt gerade
noch von anderen gemüsen belegt sind
wenn man jetzt tänzchen im haus vor
zieht dann haben die jetzt schon in
wachstumsvorsprung können schon mal
anfangen zu wachsen während die anderen
beete noch belegt sind und dann kann man
die später in den garten pflanzen wenn
der platz ist das ist also der vorteil
wenn man im haus vorzieht und deswegen
ziehe ich auch jetzt wenn ganze menge
gemüse noch im haus vor auch wenn es
schon september ist und wir fangen an
mit dem winter portugal oder winter
postel 1 das ist sehr unbekanntes gemüse
eigentlich eher so eine art salat würde
ich sagen total mit total lecker sehr
gesund wächst absolut problemlos in den
kalten monaten also echt eine ganz tolle
sache ich sträuße da jetzt immer so
sagen wir mal 34 samen pro töpfchen in
die erde
und bedecke die mit erde das ist ganz
wichtig dass man wartet bis es ein
bisschen kühler als draußen
weil die können nur greifen wenn es
unter zwölf grad ist zumindest nachts
aber das ist jetzt gerade kein problem
wir sind gerade relativ kühl ist es ja
sowieso ein sehr kühler sommer ansonsten
kann man die samen auch in den
kühlschrank legen und da kam
ist mir aber zu aufwendig ich warte dann
lieber noch ein bisschen länger man kann
die auch im oktober noch aussehen bis es
dann soweit ist ja bald braucht es auch
wieder am start
war praktisch gerade wenn es sowieso
feine damen geht die sage vom basteln
sind super fein
damit die eben nicht verschleppt werden
oder wegschwimmen so machen wir weiter
mit dem rheingold den man jetzt auch im
haus vorziehen ich mache das um den
später ins gewächshaus zu pflanzen
ansonsten kann man sich auch noch im
prepaid kasten pflanzen wenn man die
jetzt seht aber ansonsten ist es für
mangold jetzt auch schon langsam ein
bisschen spät wenn man den jetzt das
freiland vorzieht dann erdet man halt
nur noch sehr kleine blätter wobei der
auch sehr sehr frost hat ist also den
kann man auch im winter im weg stehen
lassen der wächst dann nur halt nicht
großartig weiter das ist immer die sache
mit den wintergemüse da muss man
rechtzeitig daran denken wenn es richtig
kalt wird dann können die zwar einiges
ab also die meisten gemüse sie können
viel mehr frost wegstecken als man ihnen
zutraut aber so richtig weiter wachsen
tun die dann eben nicht hilfe die
sondern einigermaßen großen
wachstumsvorsprung bevor es dann richtig
kalt wird draußen beim mangold baue ich
am allerliebsten die sorte rainbow ort
mich schon oft erzählt hier auf dem
kanal hat richtig schönen bunten stangen
der da hielt er immer im haus mit dabei
ist daniel krumme einer der coolsten
kurs teilnehmer überhaupt aus
gemüsegarten staaten mehr hatten wir
eine riesen packung mit wayne gesagt
krieg so geschickt nachdem ich letztes
mal gesagt habe dass das ist mir das
ausgegangen ist zutrieb dankeschön
daniel du bist echt der witzigste typ
überhaupt ich mache weiter weil der
spieler
da sehe ich jetzt die sorte winter
riesen oder wer die laus die hat zwei
namen irgendwie noch einmal richtig an
gießen alle
kann dir so gut fangen
ich habe fast vergessen sie konnte mir
das passieren ich glaube jeder der
meinen kanal kennt und auch nur drei
videos gesehen hat der weiß
ich ein absolut riesenposter fan von der
winter salatsorten backe bin leider sehr
sehr schwierig nur zu bekommen also wenn
ihr mal die gelegenheit habe den
irgendwo zu kaufen dann auf jeden fall
sofort zuschlagen weil er immer sofort
ausverkauft ist aber dass so eine
geniale sollte die ist absolut forst hat
also da muss es schon richtig richtig
kalt sein dass er überhaupt frostschäden
bekommt habe ich fast noch nie erlebt
ehrlich gesagt und den kann man den
ganzen winter über einfach so beenden
das ist so eine tolle angelegenheit ja
der ist auch noch in der erde der winter
kann computer sein opfer gedacht haben
ohne papiere in den winter geben wie nie
das machen wir nicht machen wir mit den
gemüsen weiter die wir jetzt direkt ins
beet sehen können das ist zum einen der
feldsalat dafür ist jetzt wirklich zeit
damit er dann bist du die kalten monate
auch richtig schön groß geworden ist
muss man den jetzt in die erde bringen
ich mache das immer breit würfel kreft
die samen aller ob die erde streut die
möglichst gleichmäßig auf dem boden aus
und dann hab ich die mit der hacke so
ein bisschen ein so ist für mich auf
jeden fall die aussaat viel leichter als
wenn ich das alles fein säuberlich in
reihen machen muss ich kann zwischendrin
die großen pflanzen ernten so dass die
anderen mehr platz haben um wachsen zu
können und so ist der ertrag bei uns
auch einfach viel höher pro fläche
gebaut er immer auch sorten teams haben
hier habe ich die sorte wehrt ab
ich hoffe ich habe das richtig
ausgesprochen ansonsten auch noch eine
sorte die ich richtig gerne anbau ist
wer die konkrete pläne es euch hier
unten ein dann wisst ihr wie es
geschrieben wird machen wir weiter mit
einem anderen tollen salat der ganz
anders schmeckt nämlich viel schärfer
das ist der asia salat da sehe ich jetzt
mal so eine mischung aus mit roten
blättern und grünen blättern ist richtig
cool um mal so einen winterlichen salat
so ein bisschen aufzupeppen der ist
wirklich sehr scharf es ist sicher nicht
jedermanns geschmack man kann davon auch
nicht so viel essen als nicht alles voll
sehen das ist ja gerade das ist auch ein
kreuzblütler ist auch gerade mit der
fruchtfolge dann nicht so ganz einfach
weil ganz viele gemüse ja aus der
familie der kreuzblütler kommen zum
beispiel der kohlrabi der weißkohl
rotkohl blumenkohl broccoli und so
weiter und das ist eine pflanzenfamilie
die gleichzeitig aber auch sehr anfällig
ist will ganz viele schädlinge und
krankheiten und deswegen muss man da
immer eine ganz lange an baupause
einhalten von 56 jahren
bis das gleiche gemüse aus dieser
familie wieder auf einem beet wachsen
kann deswegen ist glaube ich bei den
meisten von uns der platz für
kreuzblütler asse ein bisschen rar im
garten wenn man denn die fruchtfolge
richtig einhalten möchte wovon ich ein
großer verfechter bin deswegen ist es
vielleicht gar nicht so verkehrt vom
aasee salat nicht so viele sondern ein
bisschen dezenter gleich die lücken zu
füllen die jetzt in den coolen beten
entstanden sind so dass ihr da jetzt in
diesem jahr nochmal einen kreuzblütler
anbaut der aber dann im winter aktiv ist
so dass nächstes jahr eine andere
pflanzen familie wachsen kann und jetzt
kommt ein richtig cooles gemüse das ist
die winter erbse da habe ich die sollte
sie mal an die kann man nicht planen und
dann nächstes jahr richtig frieren wir
sagen also sagen immer in meissen die
dann erntereif wenn die anderen ärzten
immer noch so ein bisschen brauchen das
ist der große vorteil von denen die
überwintern auch sehr sehr zuverlässig
also jetzt im winter war es ja minus 22
grad hier im garten und da sind ja sie
hat ein paar forstschäden aber wirklich
nicht viel wir hatten eine super ernte
im mai also echt eine tolle sorten
empfehlung probiert das auf jeden fall
mal aus und kann man jetzt auch wenn man
sich noch bei all das ist vielleicht
anfang september wenn du das video
schaut kannst du auch noch
ein asiatischer wohl auch wieder also
vorsicht aber
ein super super leckeres super mildes
tolles sehr sehr schnell wachsendes
gemüse absolute empfehlung von meer und
diesem wunderschön ich hoffe ich habe
ein paar aufnahmen gemacht für meine
ernte dieses jahr dass ich die euch
einblenden kann falls nicht nun werde
ich spätestens jetzt eben jetzt
nachholen und ja absolute empfehlung
wirklich es gibt so viele gemüse die
viele leute gar nicht auf dem schirm
haben und ich finde sie mal ganz schade
dass viele leute immer nur das gleiche
gegen wiese im garten anbauen obwohl sie
nur so viel mehr zu entdecken gibt dann
den kandidaten wir eben gerade vergessen
haben in baku den winter soldat den kann
man jetzt auch direkt ins freiland
zählen die dafür platz habe ich bau den
im winter immer als pflücksalat an das
heißt ich streue wie beim feldsalat auch
so großflächig da die samen einfach auf
die erde so dass die pflanzen sehr dicht
wachsen
und dann endlich nach bedarf immer die
einzelnen blätter schneidet die so vier
zentimeter über dem boden ab und dann
kann er wieder nachwachsen das
funktioniert wunderbar und geht viel
besser als wenn man versucht den als
kopfsalat im winter an zu bauen dann
wenn es richtig kalt wird vielleicht
nicht mit einem vlies schützen und dann
habt ihr den ganzen winter über euren
eigenen salat stellt euch mal vor an
weihnachten der familie den eigenen
salat aufzutischen und vielleicht noch
mit einem selbst geernteten kohlrabi
nämlich auch der winter fest übrigens
hier habe ich auch noch etwas was den
winterlichen salatteller ein bisschen
aufhübschen und zwar die rote garde die
kann man jetzt auch noch sein ist ein
sehr tolles gemüse ist der eigentlich
nur unkraut da die melde im auto in
anführungszeichen kaut man kann
natürlich auch die normale wilde melde
essen aber die route ist noch ein
bisschen feiner von blättern herd und
natürlich viel hübscher dass sie
wirklich unglaublich aus dem man diese
roten blättern mit den salat gibt ganz
tolle anbau erzählung und die lässt sich
auch sehr leicht selber weiterführen
also einfach paar exemplare blühen
lassen ich finde das immer bei den
gemüsen wo sich das anbietet also wo das
so leicht ist wenn ich das immer super
toll ich dick hat und so nachbarn aber
auch blühende rote melde dastehen können
bald ihre samen irgend total schön auch
wenn sich die so hatten dann nach und
nach in den eigenen garten anpassen ist
eine super sache
dann machen wir weiter mit dem spieler
weder die sorten empfehlung winter
riesen oder werden eine andere sorte die
ich auch sehr sehr gerne im winter
anders die sorte matador habe ich
vielleicht auch gelegen nämlich nicht
die nehmen sich nicht wie also die
werden bei mir beide bombastisch das ist
wirklich unglaublich
wie der spieler hat bei uns im april das
ist so eins der gemüse das da kann gar
nichts schiefgehen meine ab
genau wie streue ich auch breitflächig
auf dem boden aus einfach weil es viel
einfacher ist und viel schneller geht
also da hat man ein beet innerhalb von
sagen wir mal ein zwei minuten eingesät
und wenn man die regie und so weiter
sieht das vielleicht ein bisschen
schöner aus am ende aber muss ja ein
bisschen darauf dass er gar nicht so
viel arbeit macht das auf jeden fall
mein motto gemacht mangold können wir
auch aussehen aber nur diejenigen von
euch die ihnen flügel kasten haben oder
ein gewächshaus da könnt ihr den jetzt
auch direkt in die erde sehen das
gleiche gilt für karotten aber nur für
eine spezielle sorte die sorte
gonsenheimer treibt vielleicht gibt es
noch andere mögen die jetzt noch gehen
aber die kenne ich nicht ich wohl wenn
ich so spät noch karotten aussehe dann
immer die sorte gonsenheimer treibt eine
sehr kurze sehr schnell wachsende auch
leckere karotte die sehe ich jetzt bei
mir in den freeway kasten und ins
gewächshaus aber nach draußen da wird es
glaube ich nichts mehr also die brauchen
nun schon eine ganze weile bis die alte
reif sind und dass sich wieder dem ende
zum einen sieht er übrigens ich glaub
man sie das nicht ich hoffe aber ich bin
super dreckig weil ich gerade kartoffeln
geerntet habe und schaut euch meine
fingernägel an aber so hat sich darauf
als gärtner oder gar zum guten ton ist
ja winter postel ein könnt ihr jetzt
auch direkt nach draußen sehen hatten
wir ja eben auch schon den der anzug den
feldsalat kann man jetzt übrigens auch
im haus vorziehen um dann noch einmal
darauf zurückzukommen bis mir nur zu
viel arbeit irgendwie für so ein kleines
winziges gemüse wo man so viel von
braucht deswegen lieber direkt ins beet
aus aber wenn ihr jetzt wirklich noch
gar keinen platz habt in eurem beten
oder unbedingt feldsalat anschauen wollt
dann könnt ihr ihn auf jeden fall auch
im haus vorziehen und ein genieße das
immer geht wenn man nach draußen aus
sein möchte so bis in den oktober hinein
ist das radieschen
dadurch die sollte so an und da kann man
auch super toll im cold eben wegen der
fruchtfolge dann auf dem holzbrett wenn
ein kohl abgeerntet ist superschön
lücken füllen die wachsen so schnell
auch gerade wenn man mit kindern gärtner
tja manchmal ein bisschen ungeduldiger
sind als wir großen leute ist das eine
super schöne sache weil man eben
superschnell den ersten erfolg hat das
nächste gemüse dass er jetzt auswählen
könnt er vor allem diejenigen von euch
die eintritt kosten oder ein gewächshaus
haben ist die gartenkresse auch ein sehr
witziges gemüse dass man den ganzen
winter über bewerten kann und dann könnt
ihr jetzt auch noch die dicken boden aus
wenn ich sehe wie immer im september
viele leute bauen die erste richtung
februar an im frühjahr aber wenn man die
jetzt schon geld und die können sehr gut
im beet überwintern vor allem diese
sorte hier hängen da und grünkern ich
heißt die vielfalt ist es jetzt viel
sinnvoller die jetzt aus zu sehen weil
die wohnen die überwintern und schon
diesem wachstumsvorsprung haben im
frühjahr sind erstens früher alt und die
schließen perfekt diese lücke im mai und
juni wenn das ganze wintergemüse
aufgegessen ist die kartoffeln im lager
schuldig geworden sind die rote bete
nicht mehr schmeckt wie man eingelagert
hat aber der garten trotzdem noch nicht
die ernte april bzw eigentlich nur salat
und so grün zeigt was ab toll ist aber
nicht so richtig krachen mit substanz
also das ist eben diese handelt die im
mai und juni entsteht und da kommt den
dicke bohne rein wenn jetzt das nicht
laut
jedenfalls die dicke bohne die kommt
dann an den start und wird richtig viel
ertrag ab macht ein richtig satt und
deswegen sie oder ich ziehe die nicht wo
ich sehe die jetzt im september aus um
dann eben diese ernte verfügung zu haben
und noch ein argument warum das jetzt
sinnvoll ist die dicken boden werden
super schnell von der schwarzen bodenlos
angefallen und diejenigen die
überwintert haben und im frühling schon
relativ groß sind im vergleich zu denen
die man erst im frühling city sind viel
weniger anfällig für die schwarze bohnen
laos ich habe tatsächlich noch nie
schwarze wohnhäuser an den boden gehabt
die ich im september gewählt habe
deswegen unbedingt ausprobieren dicke
bohnen wieder ein gemüse dass man kaum
im laden bekommt was super schade ist
weil es einen der besten leckersten
luise ist die man überhaupt im garten
anbauen kann machen wir weiter mit den
gewesen die man jetzt nach draußen ins
beet pflanzen kann das ist wie das
fertige pflänzchen in speed pflanzen und
nicht sehen da sehen natürlich alle
gemüse dazu ich bisher erwähnt habe ich
will nochmal euch an den salat erinnern
also wenn ihr zum beispiel auf dem
wochenmarkt jetzt noch paar salat
quäntchen abstauben könnt dann nehmt die
mitte 20 noch in euren garten weil die
form winter noch ne tolle ernte haben
könnte diejenigen von euch die ihnen
fremd kasten oder im gewächshaus haben
können jetzt auch probieren noch mal ein
paar kohl pflänzchen zu setzen ich habe
das letztes jahr zum ersten mal
ausprobiert und das hat unglaublich gut
funktioniert und zwar habe ich
blumenkohl und brokkoli jetzt um die
jahreszeit ungefähr unter meine tomaten
pflanzen gepflanzt und die im
gewächshaus überwintern lassen natürlich
muss man wenn man die tomaten dann raus
nimmt aufpassen dass man nicht auf die
kleinen pflänzchen drauf tritt aber das
hat super gut funktioniert obwohl mein
gewächshaus kaputt ist schon seit
ewigkeiten da regnet es auch rein hatte
ich auch jetzt gerade muss sich ein paar
pflanzen legen braunfäule rausnehmen
weil das hat man so gemerkt den
unterschied zwischen wo es reinregnet
und wo es nicht reinregnet jedenfalls
habe ich die einfach im gewächshaus
überwintern lassen und hatte dann im
april eine supertolle ernte ich habe das
wie gesagt erst ein jahr ausprobiert das
wird auch nicht offiziell so empfohlen
in irgendwelchen garten es war eher so
ein experiment weil warum nicht mal was
neues ausprobieren und das war ja
richtig kalt im winter es war minus 22
grad und es hat trotzdem wunderbar
funktioniert obwohl ich karl forster im
gewächshaus hatte weil eben ein
dachfenster fehlt bzw eine ganze dach
scheibe und draußen zwar schnee lag da
isoliert die gemüse die draußen wachsen
im gewächshaus lag natürlich kein schnee
und dann hat's richtig rein gefahren
alle möglichen gemüse sind mir deswegen
kaputt gegangen das war eine richtig
dumme sachen ich werde auf jeden fall da
eine scheibe rein machen bevor es kalt
wird aber das war trotzdem so ein
erfolgreiches experiment das müsst ihr
auf jeden fall mal ausprobieren wenn ihr
die möglichkeiten habt und übrigens es
ist auch gar nicht schwer in den freeway
kasten zu bauen auf einem hochbeet drauf
bzw ja das einfache und auf den rahmen
mit
deckeln die ich dann jetzt bevor es kalt
wird danach dran schraube und so kann
man seine ernte so früh im frühling und
im winter immer noch so viele tolle
sachen anbauen also diejenigen von euch
die ein hochbeet sowieso im garten
stehen haben sollten dass auf jeden fall
machen man kann aber auch einfach so ein
frühbeet aufsatz für ein ebenerdiges
beet bauen und den dann im herbst
einfach darauf stehen eine suppe
angelegenheit super projekt vielleicht
diesem regentag in der werkstatt was er
jetzt auch unbedingt pflanzen sollte
sind winter steckt zwiebeln falls ihr
das noch nie ausprobiert habt es ist
wirklich richtig cool es gibt sieben
sorten die kann man jetzt pflanzen und
dann sehr früh nächstes jahr ernten ich
lernte da auch immer das zwiebel grünen
den ganzen winter über das heißt ich
schneide das auch ungefähr vier
zentimeter über dem boden ab altig
frühlingszwiebeln einfach das ist
wirklich schön im winter immer noch
eigenes viel grün zu haben und die sind
so frost hat das ist unglaublich ich bin
immer wieder beeindruckt wenn es
wirklich klirrend kalt draußen ist und
die stehen da und du denkst oh gott was
denn die autoren wie werden noch
matschig sein die tank auf und sehen aus
als ob nichts passiert wäre
es gibt ja auch gemüse die ihr eigenes
frostschutzmittel herstellen das ist
super faszinierend ich bin immer wieder
super bafta von pflanzen eigentlich
können und wenn ihr eben das ziel grün
ernten wollte von ihren winter zwiebeln
dann so eine handvoll zwiebeln aus die
zwiebel grünpflanzen sind die ihr immer
wieder beerntet die wachsen nämlich auch
toll wieder nach und lass die anderen in
ruhe weil von denen wollte er
wahrscheinlich die dicken zwiebeln
ernten und das wird nichts wenn man das
grün immer wieder abschneidet und die
pflanzen keine ordentliche photosynthese
machen können dann werden die auch am
ende keine dicken knollen ausbilden
können deswegen auf jeden fall
unterscheiden zwischen denen die man
flexibel grün an bord von denen die man
geben später als richtige zwiebeln oder
gemüse zwiebeln ernten möchte und
genauso wie die winter steckt zwiebeln
kennt er jetzt da sollte ich jetzt auch
knoblauch stecken das ist wirklich die
beste pflanzzeit jetzt im september und
oktober
täglich daran denken die knollen werden
nämlich viel viel dicker sein ich habe
zum klub auch anbau schon mal ein video
gemacht wo ich genau erklären was man
beachten muss damit man am ende auch
eine richtig tolle ernte einfährt also
auf jeden fall da trieben vorbei weil
das steht jetzt auf dem programm
ansonsten geht raus macht die welt ein
bisschen grüner und wir sehen uns
nächsten samstag wieder für ein sehr
besonderes video wo ich jetzt schon
wochenlang daran arbeite da könnt ihr
euch auf jeden fall drauf freuen bis
dann nichts gutes